how many exorcisms about have you
performed
well there are different levels of
exorcism because the church says there's
four different types of
extraordinary demonic activity there's
demonic infestation which is the
presence of evil and the location or
associated with an object
there can be demonic vexation which
are physical attacks that somebody's
receiving there can be bites and bruises
and marks that appear on the skin
people might even remember the incisions
of letters from movies they've watched
that will pop up on the skin you've seen
that you've seen letters just on
appear on someone's skin and how do you
know that somebody didn't self-mutilate
or that somebody didn't do that to them
how do you know that's a spirit because
they appear right in front of me so it's
not like they walk you're sitting in
front of someone and just letters appear
on their skin yes
wow see right then and there i'd be like
i need a coffee break i need something
maybe not coffee but something wow
that's and then i was going to say then
there's demonic obsession which are
mental attacks and then demonic
possession which
is when the demon takes control of the
person's body so if we're talking about
the actual demon contain taking control
of a body how many of those would you
say you do in a year or overall just i
need a ballpark number of how much
exposure you'd have
like one a year one a year yes okay so
it's rare is it rare that people we know
that possession itself is rare but is it
rare that people come to you and claim
they're being possessed or is that much
more common that filtration process what
does it look like
well because i'm publicly known there
are many exorcists who prefer to remain
anonymous but when my bishop appointed
me he wanted me to go out and to help
educate
the faithful and even other people about
what the church believes and teaches
about exorcism and because i'm publicly
known i probably
receive a higher volume of inquiries i
currently average about 70 a week
70 inquiries a week from people all over
the united states and even other parts
of the world who are seeking the help of
the church
and
then you begin the filtration process of
like who who's really potentially
possessed how does that work then do you
involve mental health professionals to
kind of gauge this do you do it yourself
how do you decide which case is at that
point of those 70 a week
merit your attention in a spiritual way
well as an exorcist i cannot function
outside of my diocese so i can't
function outside of the archdiocese of
indianapolis because technically the
bishop of the diocese is the exorcist so
i act in his name for me to function
outside of the archdiocese of
indianapolis i would need permission of
the other local bishop
so if somebody contacts me from outside
of indianapolis what i try to do is
connect them
with a priest or someone in their area
so i try to help them find a local
connection
but for people who are local yeah there
is a process so what does that look like
there's a protocol that we use in the
united states
so step one of the protocol would be for
the person to have a psychiatric
evaluation sometimes people fight back
on that but the truth is if somebody's
really in dealing with the demonic they
need to be in a good place mentally
before going through the right of the
church
and then also there there needs to be a
physical examination by a medical doctor
to rule out any physical cause
third step of the protocol i would meet
with the person and do an intake
questionnaire trying to determine
how did evil enter into this person's
life one might say that we want to
isolate
the presence of the demonic in the
person
so that we know how best to fight it i
would look for four signs of
possibility of true demonic possession
there are four things so it's the
ability to speak and understand
languages otherwise unknown to the
individual
having superhuman strength beyond the
normal capacity of the individual having
elevated perception
so the person is saying things that they
should not otherwise know which would
lead me to know that that's a demon
speaking and not that person as an
individual
and then an aversion to anything of a
sacred nature such as being blessed with
holy water being shown a crucifix having
the bible read in front of them
being in a church you name it anything
that's sacred that would cause a
negative reaction could be the sign of a
demonic presence and then step five of
the protocol is the most important
it's helped the person to resume the
spiritual life
or to find god for the very first time
because as an exorcist
even though i'm a catholic priest more
than half the people who contact me are
not catholic
so they come from other christian faith
traditions other world religions or no
faith background whatsoever
but it's not enough just to cast the
demon out
it's very very important that god has to
be invited in i've seen a growing trend
today with
faith is in decline in the lives of many
people that people who believe they're
dealing with the demonic will now view
the exorcist as a type of a magician
so people believe that i have
special powers or abilities or i have a
few tricks up my sleeve that i can make
all their problems go away
but ultimately
god is the one who's going to do that
and he will act through the church and
through the church's ministers if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]